يا
[موسيقى]
بابا البق رحلهم يا
اخوي هذو قع تاع
الناس السبه وال
[موسيقى]
البقبوق سكواس اخويا شنو
هذا هربت سلك يا اخويا باريس تعلن حاله
الطوارئ محتل جديد يبغ فرنسا ويحتل
منازلها وقطارات واماكنها العامه حتى دور
السينما لم تسلم منه واجبر الجميع على رمع
عفشهم الى الشارع ذلك العدو الذي لا يتعدى
طوله 6ه مليمترات بحجمه الصغير وبلونه
البني المائل للاحمرار وكانه مصاص دماء لا
بل انه بالفعل مصص دماء ولا يتغذى الا على
الدماء بق الفراش هذا الك الئن الصغير جعل
فرنسا في موقف محرج العالم يوجه رساله
لاحفاد لواس قبل ان تنتقدوا الاخرين نظفوا
انفسكم اولا لا يا عزيزي ليست نظافه
سياسيه هذه المره بل هي النظافه الشخصيه
نعم احفاد لواس الذين لاطالما انتقدوا
مظهر غيرهم هاهم اليوم ضحيه لعدو نظافتهم
الشخصيه ولكنهم كعادتهم يلصق التهمه
بغيرهم قائلين لقد جاء بها الافارقه
والمهاجرون مهلا الم تمتص
ثرواتهم اليوم ياتي من يمتص دمائكم فيا ل
العداله الاقدار ما هي الحشره التي اجتاحت
فرنسا واثارت الهلع بين الفرنسيين ولماذا
وصفت تلك الحشره بفم باير او مصاص دماء
رغم ان حجمها اصغر من حجم بذره التفاح
لتعرف اجابه كل تلك الاسئله تابع الفيديو
للنهايه مصاص دماء يرعب عاصمه
النور اجتاحت حشره بق الفراش دلوعه اوروبا
ونقصد هنا فرنسا الحشره الصغيره تملا كل
مكان في باريس وتثير الهلع بين الناس
تجدها في كل مكان في الشوارع على الجدران
والاسطح وحتى على مقاعد وسائل النقل
العامه السلطات الفرنسيه تستغيث الوضع في
طريقه للخروج عن السيطره وزير النقل
الفرنسي وعد الجميع بالاجتماع مع مسؤولي
وسائل النقل لبحث سبل مواجهه بق الفراش
اما نائب عمده باريس ايمانويل غريغوار وصف
الامر بالكارثي قائلا عليك ان تفهم انه في
الواقع لا يوجد احد في مامن من الواضح ان
هناك عوامل خطر ولكن في الواقع يمكنك
التقاط بق الفراش من اي مكان واعادته الى
المنزل وصحفي فرنسي يضع باسكال برود يلصق
التهمه بغير الفرنسيين قائلا هل نعرف
لماذا يوجد الكثير من البق اليوم هل له
علاقه بالنظافه نشهد حاليا هجره كثيفه هل
الاشخاص الذين لا يمتنعون عن النظافه
الشخصيه كتلك الموجوده في فرنسا هم الذين
يجلبون يريد برود الصاق تهمه انتشار بقي
الفراش في باريس بالمهاجرين او بمعنى ادق
الى الاجانب غير الفرنسيين الذين دخلوا
فرنسا الفتره الماضيه وكان اي تقدم ينسب
الى باريس واي شيء اخر ينسب لغيرها وان
كان في داخلها ولكن مهلا يبرود فماذا عن
الطاعون الذي اجتاح فرنسا في العصور
الوسطى وحصد ارواح الملايين بسبب الفئران
وعدم اهتمامكم بنظافتهم من الذي جلبه
اليكم هل هم المهاجرون ايضا انتم دائما
تنكرون الحقائق حتى وان كانت واضحه ولكن
لماذا اثار بق الفراش كل هذا الهلع في
فرنسا رغم صغر حجمه دراكولا
الحشرات تعتبر حشره بق الفراش من اشرس
الحشرات الموجوده على ظهر الارض لونها بني
مائل للحمره وذلك لانها تعيش على مص
الدماء ليس لها اجنحه ولكن وجودها في اي
مكان يثير الهلع يوجد 100 نوع منها ولا
تصيب البشر فقط بل ايضا تصيب الطيور وحتى
الخفافيش تخيل يا عزيزي ان تلك الحشره
التي لا يتعدى حجمها السبعه ملليمترات تمص
دماء واحد من اشرس مصص الدماء ونقصد هنا
الخفاش لتلك الحشره قدره رهبه على التكاثر
فهي تضع نحو 500 بيضه سنويا وتستطيع ان
تعيش دون طعام او شراب لقراه 12 شهرا اي
سنه كامله حتى وان كانت في ظروف جويه صعبه
فهي لا تتاثر بال الحراره او الرطوبه
والكارثه الاكبر هي ان بق الفراش اصبح
لديه مناعه قويه ضد اقوى المبيدات الحشريه
وكانها تعلنها للبشر لا يهمني تطورهم
العلمي ساعيش وامص دمائكم مهما فعلتم اي
مصيبه حلت عليك يا
باريس اختفاء
وعوده اختفى بق الفراش تماما في اواسط
القرن الماضي ولكنه هذا وظهر مره اخرى
خلال ال سنه الماضيه اما بالنسبه للبيئه
المناسبه لتلك الحشره فهي تعشق كل ما
يكرهه الانسان كالاما غير النظيفه مع
توافر الغذاء ونقصد هنا الدم بالطبع وغير
معروف حتى الان لماذا انتشرت بهذه الدرجه
في فرنسا تحديدا ومن هو المسؤول الحقيقي
عن ظهورها هناك مره اخرى السؤال الان لكم
مشاهدينا هل ستخرج الامور عن السيطره
يتحول بق الفراش الى ظاهره تهدد بقاء
البشر في باريس وهل حقا اجتياح تلك الحشره
في فرنسا يرجع في حقيقته الى المهاجرين
غير الفرنسيين ام ان احفاد لوس كانوا
يصدرون لنا صورا غير حقيقيه عن نظافتهم
الشخصيه اخبرونا في صندوق
[موسيقى]
التعليقات
ه